now that you're doing stand up and I
love the name of your
tour and I I have it right here and I'm
gonna I'm gonna read it off this piece
of paper
because that's how I work I like to
include people in the process so they
can see behind the scenes what's
happening all right you're turning the
country and the name of the tour is the
only former U.S senator currently on
tour
I love that now I'm gonna say what it
was are you mostly talking are you
talking about current events a lot in
your stand-up are you talking about your
years in the Senate it's sort of
biographical so how I became you know
like zielinski right is considered now
probably the bravest person and of
course comedian bravest profession yeah
I believe so yeah yeah podcaster maybe
third
um that sounds right as profession yeah
uh but of comedians Jewish comedians
the bravest
and uh then well the Irish of course
Jewish comedians who go into politics
like zelenski the bravest yeah so so
then I talk about how I became one of
the basically the second bravest person
so it's biographical and then I get to
me and the Senate and they talk about
you know
those colleagues and
and then I go yeah and then I go into
some stuff that's happening now you know
zielinski famously uh Putin invades and
the
United States reaches out and says we
can airlift you out of there right away
and he says I need guns not a ride such
a cool line
now perfect Al you in that same
situation I see you fleeing with a
suitcase
running running with a suitcase that
keeps flapping open
and long underwear falls out and you've
got to stop and shove it back in and
then you keep running true or false
I've thought about this myself I mean it
was ballsy I mean he said I don't want
to ride I want an ammunition and that
was pretty I have to ask you either
you're you're married to a guy from
Russia but he's from Armenia which was
part of the Soviet Union oh yeah but he
I mean he speaks Russian and Tack has
children's toys that are from his youth
yeah
yeah in the Soviet Union uh where you
little little children's toys do your
kids play with The Little Soviet toys
they love those Soviet toys they're cute
you pull the string and it says get in
line for bread
yeah we start a podcast about uh
American versus Soviet toys called
perestoica that's Paris
listen to that that's great well those
would be French toys
okay
God goodbye hey wait thank you hey wait
a minute Al this is very rare but the
new low light has just gone off
he's standing he's still standing
standing wow this is the longest Ovation
amazing uh wow look just
taking in all the love
promise Paris toika
it would be French toys
every time you came on my show in the
late night show years and years and
years you'd come on and at the end
you would do an insane dance up and down
the aisles running and running and
burning all these calories and the
audience loved it and then I think you
never ran it nine times out of ten if
not ten times out of 10 it got cut for
time oh that you've been you must have
you worked so hard on that ending and it
was fantastic I think it got in once I'm
not sure it did now this was
um
uh The Comedy of energy
that's all it was right it's called what
they used to call it in Vaudeville was a
sweat Act
yes they would say it's a sweat out
there's just a lot of jumping around and
then of course Jack Benny or you know
there are other what was the theme
that's the end of the thing you can sing
the theme of the show
oh here we go
you have to imagine a big stairway okay
and I would just
you're like
yeah
and it lasted for ever oh this
song would go and go and go and I think
the band didn't want to cut you off so
they'd keep it going your resting heart
rate when you were done was something
like 265 and uh and then because the
show would end with me saying all right
you know tomorrow Lenny Kravitz and then
Bang
out completely out and there was all
this wasted energy yeah and there was
not seen by the American public it was
still worth it to entertain you and
entertain me and entertain the 185
people that were in that room that's
right that's right and that's all
so I can make just
profit I don't know if you know he's a
community of Minnesota who's a great
writer said if I can make just one
person laugh
then I know it's a Tuesday night at The
Comedy Store
laughs